what advice would you give to young
folks today
you know operating in um
in this complicated space about how to
have a successful life a life they can
be proud of a career they can be proud
of
maybe somebody in high school and
college thinking about what they're
going to do
be a hacker
you know if you have any interest become
a hacker
and apply yourself to defense
you know every time like we do have
these these amazing scholarship programs
for instance where you know they find
you early they'll pay your college as
long as you
um commit to some kind of federal
commitment to sort of help federal
agencies with cyber security and where
does everyone want to go every year from
the scholarship program they want to go
work at the nsa or cyber command you
know they want to go work on offense
they want to go do the sexy stuff it's
really hard to get people to work on
defense
it's just it's always been more fun to
be a pirate than being the coast guard
you know and so
we have a huge deficit when it comes to
filling those roles there's 3.5 million
unfilled cyber security positions around
the world i mean talk about job security
like be a hacker and work on cyber
security you will always have a job
and we're actually at a huge deficit
and disadvantage as a free market
economy
um because we can't match
cyber security salaries at palantir or
facebook or google or microsoft and so
it's really hard for the united states
to fill those roles um
and you know other countries have had
this workaround where they basically
have forced conscription on some level
you know china tells people
like you do whatever you're gonna do
during the day work at alibaba you know
if you need to do some ransomware okay
but the minute we tap you on the
shoulder and ask you to come do this
sensitive operation for us the answer is
yes um you know same with russia you
know a couple years ago when yahoo was
hacked and they laid it all out in an
indictment it came down to two cyber
criminals and two guys from the fsb
cyber criminals were allowed to have
their fun but the minute they came
across the username and password for
someone's personal yahoo account that
worked at the white house or the state
department or military they were
expected to pass that over to the fsb
so we don't do that here and it's it's
even worse on defense we really can't
fill these positions
so you know be if if you are a hacker if
you're interested in code if you're a
tinker
you know learn how to hack
um
there are all sorts of amazing hacking
competitions you can do through um the
sans org for example s-a-n-s
uh and then use those skills for good
you know neuter the bugs in that code
that get used by autocratic regimes to
make people's life you know a living
prison
you know plug those holes you know
defend industrial systems defend our
water treatment facilities from hacks
where people are trying to come in and
poison the water
you know that i think is just an amazing
um
it's an amazing job on so many levels
it's intellectually stimulating
you can tell yourself you're serving
your country you can tell yourself
you're saving lives and keeping people
safe and you'll always have amazing job
security and if you need to go get that
job that pays you you know two million
bucks a year you can do that too and you
can have a public profile more so of a
public profile you can be a public rock
star i mean it's the same thing as uh
sort of the military and there's a lot
of
um
there's a lot of
well-known sort of
people commenting on the fact that
veterans are not treated as well as they
should be
but it's still the fact that soldiers
are deeply respected for
for uh defending the country the
freedoms the the ideals that we stand
for and in the same way
i mean in some ways the cyber security
defense are the soldiers of the future
yeah and you know it's interesting i
mean in in cyber security the difference
is oftentimes you see the more
interesting threats in the private
sector because that's where the attacks
come you know when when cyber criminals
and nation state adversaries come for
the united states they don't go directly
for cyber command or the nsa
no they go for banks they go for google
they go for microsoft they go for
critical infrastructure and so those
companies those private sector companies
get to see some of the most advanced
sophisticated
attacks
out there and you know if you're working
at fireeye
and you're calling out the solarwinds
attack for instance i mean you just
saved
god knows how many systems
from you know that compromise turning
into something
that more closely resembles sabotage
so you know go go be a hacker
and
or go be a journalist
you